el excandidato a la presidencia sina no
han que obtuvo el 5% del apoyo Popular
en las elecciones en Turquía ha dicho
esta misma tarde que va a dar apoyo a
ipedon En esta segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales aquí en
Turquía lo ha hecho ante una gran
expectación por el significado que pueda
tener este 5% de simpatizantes que la
apoyaron y que se traducen en casi tres
millones de votos que con un perfil
ultranacionalista un discurso
antirrefugiados y nunca dispuesto a
pactar con la izquierda curda esta
semana ha realizado varias consultas
para ver a quién apoyaría y finalmente
se ha decantado por erdogan recordemos
que erdogan obtuvo el
49,5% del apoyo popular Mientras que el
opositor que Malú obtuvo el
44,9% es por lo tanto
ahí perdón de en este apoyo por parte
del Tercer candidato de sinaloan una
Clara muestra de que este domingo se
puede llegar a imponer en las
presidenciales en Turquía